Tumors are showing up on CT skin as if they are growing after two months of the protocol.
Should I be concerned we should always be concerned if your tumors are growing ever two months after the protocol
We did address a question like this last week the same thing. I mean on the right for two months. How come my tumors aren't shrunk?
Hey, you you came to me and you have cancer and how fast were they growing how faster they growing now?
If they're growing as fast or faster after being on two months of any protocol you have to reassess the protocol makes some different changes.
If it's slowed down the growth the growth is still there but it's slowed down then then you might make the choice not to make any changes.
It takes time to put the brakes on something.
But certainly if let's say if I if I have objective data showing let's say I have a breast tumor pretend so the breast tumor was three millimeters a year ago and then six months later it was six
millimeters so a doubled in size it grew three millimeters and six months and then three months later I let's say I started a protocol at that six month mark and then six months later it's now you know it went from three to
six now it's let's say eight millimeters okay well it definitely slowed down its growth so I would you know you're you're you're
winning the battle somewhat here yeah it's not completely gone it's not shrinking you just continue to reassess to know that you're going in the right direction as far as momentum goes.
It's very rare that a person would go on any protocol and have there be major changes unless you want an extremely toxic protocol you can
changes with chemo in a size of a tumor more readily but but again not always so you want to reassess see if your treatment protocol needs to be tweaked or things need to be changed but I would say two months of a protocol and there's slight growth in the tumor I would make major changes.